yelling at people on Facebook great
everybody hates the gut says I don't
think everybody's I think a lot of
people like the time we're in right now
because it's so it's just I feel like
you know what you're gonna get
you know ya know it's it's a strange
time for communication man it really is
yeah strange time for everything yeah
man it's uh it's different it's so
different to it it's [ __ ] it's kind
of fascinating I had dumb they got
Jordan Peterson came out on podcast yeah
he came on your podcast yeah which was
Wow cuz I'd know his publicist and I
reached out and the publicist and then
it was wild and so then he came through
cuz I mean a lot of the people listen to
my podcast sir you know we talk a lot
about like being sober and like people
that masturbate too much kind of weird
stuff you know troubled youths kind of
I'll say it right um but anyway it was
cool because he like I don't know you
know him better than I do him he loves
you he said a lot of nice things about
oh that's nice he's a great guy he's
really misunderstood man misrepresented
people think he sunk some fascists and
some Nazi I didn't think that at all
he's not by any stretch of the
imagination he just says certain things
that people are uncomfortable hearing
and whether you agree with them or
disagree with them that's one thing but
that's the demonization is where it gets
weird even if you think he's what his
ideas foolish don't misrepresent who he
is as a person yeah they try to pretend
that he's this racist homophobic [ __ ]
alt-right character he's not by any
stretch of the imagination he's just a
guy that especially when his principles
are being debated or when his ideas are
being tested like he'll stand his ground
and he's very firm about what he thinks
is wrong about things like equality of
outcome like making sure that everybody
makes the same amount of money make sure
everybody achieves the same amount of
success like that is a ridiculous idea
that leads to communism and Marxism he
gets into it and it made me rethink how
I thought about it before then I thought
about it before then like an
unattainable goal that socialist leaned
towards because it's like the ideal the
ideal is that money's not a concern for
anybody and everybody just sort of does
whatever they want to do because they
enjoy doing it not because they're doing
it for money and that all the money's
kind of piled in together and we take
care of everybody
great on paper right but then he starts
talking about no you have to enforce the
equality of outcome right he goes when
you were talking about acquit there's
gonna be people that work harder right
it's gonna be male that try harder
there's gonna be different varying
levels of effort because we're human
beings you have to take that into
consideration as these people don't take
that into consideration it's it then
you're you're you're either trying to
stop the people that are doing too well
or you're trying to take from them to
give to yourself and how are you
enforcing this and he just takes you
down this rabbit hole of thought and
really kind of explains the problems
with Marxism and socialism and I'm sure
there's really intelligent people that
dispute his ideas I'm not saying that
his ideas are infallible or that he's
the only voice that I would listen to in
these subjects but he's a brilliant guy
and he's a very nice guy too and he's
really missing misrepresented and in
wilfully so a lot I think it's sad
because I think what's missing between
right and the left is how much fit we
would probably agree on if we just talk
about things rationally instead of
contentiously instead of getting into
these right versus left debates which
are just way too common right where
everybody's on one side is trying to
diminish the person in this side and and
get angry and they're doing a lot of
these in front of big crowds which i
think is also weird because then you're
playing to the crowd I've seen some
things that Jordan did with this Michael
Eric Dyson guy with a guy literally
wasn't looking at him is looking at the
crowd calling him a mean mad white man
and it's like these kind of things that
people are doing it's just everyone's
just digging their heels in deeper on
each side and instead of like looking at
life like just having an open
conversation about things that are
troubling things where we could do
better
things where a society needs work or
things maybe where our perceptions are
off and maybe we could look at the other
side or look at each other but look at
the whole thing better and figure out a
better way around things instead of
doing that everybody's just right versus
left and right and deeper in the
trenches and harder and we got a stop
trap and I hope we have a recession to
stop Trump and people saying crazy [ __ ]